you ask about my principles and the
first thing that comes to mind which i'm
sure we'll get to later is
my first principle is effective
governance
and i go back and
we can discuss this in more detail
alexander hamilton put it all in a
nutshell
alexander hamilton is an old treasury
guy
he's a financial guy he restored the
credit of the united states so he's a
hero of mine
he said the true test of good government
is his ability to administer not the
great policy because they carry out the
policies effectively
and economically
and good government is not just high
policy it's making the machine work
day after day
efficiently
faith of the american people in our
government today
is really distressing
you there have been polls taken every
year
ask the same question and see how the
trend changes
do you trust your government to do the
right thing most of the time
didn't sound the right thing most of the
time doesn't sound like a lot of
difficult to test
you get maybe 20 to say yes
you ask about the congress it'll be less
than 20
and it's no great secret that we're torn
apart by ideological and other
differences now
so we've got a real challenge so when
you ask my principles my first principle
is good governance